now to Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski's historic visit to Washington
he received a hero's welcome when he
arrived to speak to Congress last night
the visit came at a time when many
Republicans are now questioning U.S
spending on Ukraine's battle against
Russia while the GOP is about to take
control of the house Christina raffini
is at the White House with more on this
part of the story Christina good morning
to you he was certainly very warmly
received last night when he walked into
the chambers good morning Gail that's
right multiple standing ovations and
look he's not just his country's
commander-in-chief he's its Communicator
in Chief and in this war the battle for
hearts and Minds has been as important
to his country as ammunition the trip
yesterday was about coming to Washington
looking lawmakers in the eye and
reminding them why they should continue
to care about Ukraine
dressed in his battle greens and greeted
by an extended standing ovation
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
took his fight to Congress Ukraine is
alive
and kicking arguing that it's in
America's own interest to support
Ukraine your money is not charity
it's an investment in the global
security and democracy after enduring 11
months of Russian bombardment ukrainians
are fighting off battle fatigue not only
among their forces but from partners and
allies including the United States and
your support is crucial we have
artillery yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly not
really
zielinski's trip comes at a critical
time as Congress is set to approve a 45
billion dollar assistance package for
Ukraine the largest yet with Republicans
set to take control of Congress the
Ukrainian leader has a tough task of
trying to convince some members of the
party that this isn't open-ended
financial support you can't keep up with
it I mean we're just flushing money out
and we don't know where it's going I'm
honored to welcome you back to the White
House still in a joint press conference
earlier Wednesday President Biden told
zielinski America is in it for the long
haul American people have been with you
every step of the way and we will stay
with you we will stay with you for as
long as it takes the President also
announced that support will include a
patriot missile system
something Ukraine has long asked for
capable of shooting down Russian
aircrafts and ballistic missiles in all
weather can editions it's a defensive
weapon system it's not escalatory it's
defensive and it's easy to uh not and
we'd love to not have to have them use
it just stop the attacks but neither
leaders seem to believe a sudden
ceasefire is likely before traveling to
the U.S zielinski visited the front
lines in the embattled city of bakmut
where soldiers signed a flag he
presented to members of Congress
this flag is a symbol of our victory in
this war
We Stand we fight and we will win
because we are united Ukraine America
and the entire free wall
and after the speech Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer told CBS News he
asked Solinski privately what it would
mean if the U.S didn't pass this Aid
package Gail he said it could mean
losing the war
oh boy thank you Christina very much
before you go though where do things
stand with the efforts to pass that
government spending bill you know the
deadline is the the deadline rather is
Friday at midnight and right now it
seems that things are a little dicey
what do you think what are you hearing
well you know nothing happens in
Washington without a deadline luckily
the holidays are coming up look they
were going to try to vote on it in the
Senate last night but they didn't
adjourn until after 2 A.M it's being
held up by an amendment to continue
title 42 that's that controversial covet
border control measure but Schumer said
he's hoping they should be able to
hammer something out this morning Dale
yep we've been there before thank you
very much Christina